normally we're heading north from the
state capital passed a long line of
government troops on the move
technically there's a national ceasefire
agreement in truth it's neither
nationwide or much of a ceasefire in the
distance the silhouettes of the Shan
Mountains we're on our way to speak to
rebel fighters there who don't support
this election and say they can't sign
the government ceasefire but getting
there isn't easy further on a series of
landslides has blocked the road we're
forced to abandon our car and continue
the journey on motorbikes
is still another 38 kilometers to go
the last phase is by four-wheel-drive
we've been picked up by a rebel army
officer to be taken to a meeting point
in the mountains
the journey would be difficult in the
best of weather this is the home of the
tongue ethnic minority and an ongoing
armed insurgency guerrilla fighters from
three rebel armies have joined forces
against the government here finally out
of the forest the first of the soldiers
reveal themselves this is an infantry
patrol of the Tong National Liberation
Army sworn to protect the Tong people
they say they're fighting for equal
rights and dignity this young soldier
says he's worn out from the fighting but
he will never be tired of protecting
their land they insist they are acting
in self-defense the Tang Army has no
willingness to aggressively attack than
me and my army only to protect our
ethnic people but when the government
uses force day after day intentionally
shooting and violating the rights of the
Tong people the Tang army must respond
the conflict here has been escalating
they say they were involved in a
skirmish on the way to meet us they were
fighting a mile away from here this
morning there were clashes very close to
here earlier today the rebels blame
government forces they say they are
trying to force them to sign the
National ceasefire agreement but the
bigger problem here is trust after
fighting each other for so long they
just don't believe this government or
indeed any government backed by the
military is seriously interested in
peace Sky News was given this footage by
another rebel group the Shan State Army
north we can't verify when or where it
was filmed but they want people to
understand this is an active conflict
that means more people fleeing their
homes in this camp for so-called
internally displaced people they've been
living here so long they're eligible to
vote your song will have been here three
years this December at 72 she's lived
through all six decades of the
insurgency
we've been out view she says she wants
stability stability and development then
maybe after the election will come peace
and for people here that's what this
election is about their chances of going
home
Katy Stallard Sky News in northern Shan
State Myanmar